ohne frage wir werden auf jeden fall
immer mehr menschen auf der welt 2050 so
die prognosen sollen wir schon zehn
milliarden leute hier auf dem planeten
sein das gibt natürlich probleme und was
man da machen kann darüber wo die
letzten tage in nairobi diskutiert auf
der un weltbevölkerung konferenz da gab
es dann so maßnahmen wie mehr
geburtenkontrolle bessere
familienplanung die sollen was bringen
aber gar keine kinder mehr kriegen das
wurde dort nicht vorgeschlagen
das ist aber die these meiner heutigen
gesprächspartnerin verena braunschweiger
ist gymnasiallehrerin in regensburg und
sie vertritt diese these macht garten
uhr auszeit hat ein buch geschrieben das
sehr viel aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat
indem sie eben schreibt kinder verzicht
fürs klima ist das richtige hallo frau
braunschweiger ich habe drei kinder frau
braunschweiger bin ich in ihren augen
ist das problem
mai also wie ich schon sehr oft erklärt
es geht ja immer darum möchte ich neue
kinder bekommen und die die vorhanden
sind sozusagen schon verdienen redet
niemand also insofern da müssten sie
mich jetzt fragen wenn sie was weiß ich
jünger werden und sagen würden sie
überlegen ob sie ein kind kriegen würden
dann könnten wir noch mal klappen aber
so wo also das ist ja nicht der
gegenstand neue kinder ja ich kann ja
nur neue kinder bekommen aber ich kann
ja versuchen zum beispiel weniger zu
fliegen fleischlos zu essen
auf mein auto zu verzichten nur noch bio
zu kaufen weniger zu konsumieren ist es
dann nicht trotzdem eine sache dass man
sagen kann ja dann kann man auch kinder
kriegen
na ja der witz das eben in der tat das
hat das mit dem kind einfach der größte
beitrag ist und auf die anderen sachen
die werden zwar immer genannt aber de
facto will ja doch kein mensch machen
und mittlerweile ist es heute praktisch
schon fünf nach zwölf das heißt es
müssen alle dinge eigentlich laufen also
sie müssen im prinzip das heißt sie
müssten
es wäre gut für die umwelt wenn sie und
andere wie ich auch zb also ich meine
ich hab jetzt weder auto noch fliege ich
fleisch noch habe ich kinder und
trotzdem brauche ich eins kommen noch
was werden und dann möchte ich auch
nicht wissen wie kommen andere bei
dieser bilanz raus das ist haltepunkt
wissens wie ich mein ja nicht verstehe
dass trotzdem mal bis ein bisschen
gefragt wann sind sie zu dazu gekommen
diesen standpunkt zu vertreten gerade
als lehrerin kann man sich schon fragen
es ist nicht ein bisschen paradox ich
wohne klasse zu stellen und zu sagen
eigentlich sollte die nicht hier sein
dass wir besser für uns alle
also überhaupt nicht das hat damit gar
nichts zu tun
also ich habe ja 2020 dann auf ein neues
buch und da geht es um populäre
missverständnisse und das alpha
klassiker und dadurch mich heute auch
damit auf dass mir immer sachen
unterstellt werden von teilweise
bösartigen und oder dummen menschen die
ich so einfach nicht stehen lassen kann
und möchte weil sie einfach nicht wahr
sind und wie eingangs erwähnt geht es
tatsächlich eben um diese entscheidung
zum beispiel auch ich bin ende 30 und
ich habe jahrelang überlegt möchte ich
selber mutter werden oder nicht und um
diese entscheidungen geht es ist hat er
mit seiner dienstlichen tätigkeit
überhaupt nichts zu tun aber sie wollten
erst nicht bösartigkeit vorwerfen oder
ihnen nicht aber manch anderen wann sind
sie denn darauf gekommen dass sie
gemerkt haben okay kinderkriegen ist für
mich kein thema weil das aus ethischen
gründen für mich nicht in frage kommt
gab es da so ein aha aha moment oder ist
das ein schleichender prozess gewesen
sowohl als auch wenn ich fast sagen weil
ich ja eben mit 30 dann noch mal
geheiratet habe und wir dann überlegt
haben wollen wir so etwas machen oder
nicht und dann habe ich recherchiert und
so weil ich ja sowas nicht über das knie
brechen so wichtige entscheidung und ich
fand dann texte im angloamerikanischen
bereich und bei einer dabei wo ich
gemerkt habe
aha okay sein bestes für die umwelt
nicht so gut dieses projekt und das habe
ich dann auch mein mann gezeigt und so
weiter und natürlich der ist macht ihr
lehrer der war der leicht zu überzeugen
mit logik und so rechnen ist sein ding
und dann konnten wir feststellen ja also
das ist eigentlich
umwelt unfreundliche entscheidung und
dann kann man bei mir neu definieren
punkte dazu und der anti naturalismus
und so und dann habe ich gemerkt das
kann ich überhaupt nicht verantworten
wenn wir zu den zahlen kommen die sie
auch immer wieder erwähnen sie haben
auch gerade schon gesagt ein kind zu
kriegen das wäre der grösste also quasi
die größte umweltsünde dieser die man
machen kann begeistert immer die zahl
von 50 tonnen co2 pro jahr pro kind das
man bekommt durch die wir also zumindest
jetzt durch die ihre interviews auch in
ihrem buch diese zahl ist aber
problematisch die ist mittlerweile
eigentlich widerlegt wurden
wenn ich das mal ganz kurz erklären
diese rechnungen dieser aufgestellt
wurde von 50 tonnen co2 pro kind die
geht davon aus dass man quasi einfach
das was auf den 50
sie sollen die geht davon aus dass man
quasi den co2 ausstoß der nachkommenden
generationen mit vererbt also die werden
quasi subsumiert und dann durch die
verschiedenen generationen geteilt
außerdem wurde bei der rechnung davon
ausgegangen dass wir einfach immer
genauso viel co2 ausstoßen wie wir es
jetzt schon tun das heißt dass sie nicht
davon ausgehen dass mal weniger werden
würde halten sie diese zahl immer noch
dass sie sagen ja das ist diese zahl an
der ich mich festhalten da eigentlich
nicht also ich habe das auch schon vor
monaten mittlerweile gesagt ja scheinbar
ist es ein bisschen zu hoch gegriffen
aber es bleibt halt trotzdem de facto
der größtmögliche beitrag und insofern
nachdem wie eingangs schon erläutert hat
die anderen sachen auch einfach nicht
laufen was ich meine in der frankfurter
rundschau ich gelesen kürzlich es gibt
wieder mehr flugreisen sogar und die
leute essen auch nicht wirklich anders
kein mensch mehr irgendwie auf
irgendetwas verzichten also ich sehe
irgendwo noch nicht die positive
entwicklung
wie kommen sie denn darauf dass menschen
auch gerade auf kinderkriegen verzichten
würden wenn sie schon nicht bereits und
auch die anderen sachen zu verzichten
das ist die ich mal einen raum stellen
möchte die ich hasse dich ganz gut und
wichtig finde ich sage ja nicht dass
mich jeder zu imitieren muss oder so ich
komme noch mal auf die zahl zurück weil
die jedoch immer noch wieder zitiert
wird und glaube ich in vielen köpfen
hängen geblieben ist und sie haben auch
gerade gesagt das ist die größte zahl
aber das problem ist soweit ich weiß
gibt es nur eine studie
genau diese zahlen zu berechnen und die
wurde jetzt wieder auseinandergenommen
da haben wir mal ein statement von dr
gregor wald hat dort vom zentrum für
berlin von zentrum für regionalstudien
suchen
diese berühmte zahl die durch die
debatte geistert 58,6 tonnen
eingespartes co2 pro nicht geborenen
kind diese zahl ist tatsächlich
vollkommen unseriös berechnet worden man
hat schlicht und ergreifend die
gesamtemissionen bestimmter länder da
war deutschland auch nicht dabei aber
zum beispiel die usa einfach durch die
bevölkerungszahl dividiert wenn sie so
rechnen
dann muss nicht ein kind zu bekommen
notwendigerweise effektiver sein als
jede jede andere maßnahme
das heißt es entsteht der falsche und
sogar politisch gefährliche eindruck
dass alle anderen individuellen
maßnahmen außer dem verzicht auf das
kind irrelevant sind und das ist
tatsächlich politisch gefährlich so das
ist ein ziemlich starker vorwurf dass im
grunde das was sie bezwecken möchte
nämlich die umwelt zu retten durch diese
forderung die sie da einen raum stellen
ja alle anderen maßnahmen ad absurdum
führen würde weil die leute sagen okay
wenn ich mein kind ist es eh zu spät
na ja gar nicht das hab ich nix sagt ich
finde es trotzdem immer gut also das
habe ich auch schon in anderen
diskussionen mal geäußert wenn die leute
trotzdem weniger fliegen usw
das ist ja klar also die bemühungen es
zählt ja jede kleinste bemühung
irgendwas also das heißt ja nicht dass
man jeden anderen beitrag deswegen
automatisch abwertet oder so das ist ja
der tat nicht davon aber habe weil er
etwas politisches erwähnt hat was ich
politisch fans dieses trist finde ist
die afg propaganda die uns immer sagt
mehr deutsche kinder weil sie brauchen
wir und die sind toll und um die geht es
und das ist was politisch gefährliches
was finden sie daran politisch
gefährlich könnte es noch ein bisschen
ausführen also ich meine wir haben die
faschistischen freunde in ungarn wir
haben salvini die läger in italien und
die wollen alle möglichst viel
einheimische kinder damit dann der
geburtenknick funktionieren kann damit
die einwanderung begrenzt werden kann
also wollen wir wieder zurück in die
ns-zeit nicht nicht
da sind wir gerade beim thema um das ist
ja heute auch geht die weltbevölkerung
konferenz der un 9 milliarden dollar
sind zugesagt wurden von verschiedenen
quellen also von privaten investoren und
von staaten ziele sind hat zum beispiel
die müttersterblichkeit weltweit zu
beenden familienplanung allgemein
zugänglich zu machen weil das ist ein
großes problem und um uns mal daraufhin
stand zu bringen was wir über das thema
weltbevölkerung wissen hat nina
niebergall mal einen grafik video für
uns gemacht
wir werden immer mehr
die bevölkerung wächst aktuell leben auf
der welt 7,7 milliarden menschen bis
2060 sollen es 10,1 milliarden werden so
zumindest die prognose der vereinten
nationen weltweit werden im schnitt 25
kinder pro frau geboren in weniger
entwickelten ländern sind es deutlich
mehr
an der spitze das westafrikanischen
niger mit statistisch 6,6 kindern in
deutschland sind es hingegen nur 1,4
kinder pro frau
die gründe dafür vielfältig weniger
aufklärung andere familienmodelle
schlechterer zugang zu verhütungsmitteln
während die weltbevölkerung wächst
schrumpft deutschland aktuell leben 83,1
millionen menschen in deutschland 2060
sollen es prognosen zufolge nur noch 74
4 millionen sein
die sorge weniger menschen die arbeiten
das wirtschaftswachstum antreiben
dafür mehr menschen die auf rente oder
pflegeleistungen angewiesen sind
dass die bevölkerung weltweit wächst
bringt aber noch ganz andere probleme
mit sich denn mehr menschen brauchen
mehr nahrung das bedeutet mehr
agrarflächen für die wälder gerodet
werden müssen und das wiederum eine
belastung für unser klima und damit auch
für uns uns darüber spreche ich mit
trainer bruce schweiger
gymnasiallehrerin in regensburg hat ein
buch geschrieben mit der these besser
keine kinder kriegen um das klima zu
schützen
ich habe hier sehr viele kommentare frau
braunschweiger die haben meine kollegen
und kolleginnen für mich mal zusammen
gesammelt hier in einem google doc und
wenn ich das mal so überfliegen kommt er
immer wieder zum beispiel das statement
fragt man in afrika an in europa kommen
sowieso zu wenig kinder zur welt
oliver helbich sogar zeigen darf ich das
schon ein
ich habe noch ein paar kommentare die
möchte ich noch vorlesen bei unserer
geburtenrate ist die gefahr für die
umwelt tun eher zu vernachlässigen
sie kommen sofort dran augenblick an
habe ich noch die weltbevölkerung längst
die zu schnell da ist auch religion
keine hilfe afrika dürfte damit die
größten probleme haben also das haben
wir ja auch gerade gesehen
in unserem beitrag das eigentliche
problem liegt gar nicht in deutschland
sondern die ganz woanders das problem
liegt sehr wohl in deutschland das ist
ja gerade öfter wichtige punkt über den
ich immer versuche aufzuklären aber
scheinbar ist immer noch nicht durch ein
deutsches kind verbraucht so viel
ressourcen wie ungefähr 30 afrikanische
im schnitt im tschad 690 in berühmte 500
und deswegen ist es ganz falsch weil wir
viel zu viele ressourcen verbrauchen und
so ein lebensstil haben dass das alles
immer schlimmer wird klimawandel
technisch und dann die armen afrikaner
ausbaden müssen was wir hier ihnen ein
brocken
dann habe ich einfach mehr anstand die
leute erkennen die dann zu uns kommen ja
da habe ich auch ein kommentar dazu da
jemand jemand das bedingt jetzt eher
nach symptomen heißt nach
ursachenbekämpfung also wäre nicht allen
geholfen auch wahrscheinlich den
nachwuchs einen menschen in afrika wenn
man das system das wirtschaftssystem
anders gestaltet so dass wir eben nicht
die ressourcen wie ihre ausbeuten
ich bin ja immer klar antikapitalistisch
unterwegs da kann man nämlich auch
gleich sagen ich meine wir haben einen
unendlichen ressourcen verbraucher an
endlichen planeten und also irgendwo
geht es halten immer zusammen das thema
jetzt wie das klima beieinander ist und
insofern weniger ressourcenverbrauch
anderes wirtschaftssystem weniger leute
und wieso also nicht auch in afrika
jetzt so zu verstehen
da gibt es ja viele frauen die wie man
vor hingehört haben keinen zugang haben
zu verhütungsmitteln und dass die lieber
schön hat das leben haben mit weniger
kindern das gönne ich den auch das ist
auch klar
also da muss man die frauen dort vor ort
in pommern damit die selbstbestimmtes
machen können und aber auch bei uns eben
einfach auf dem schirm haben dass unsere
lebensweise das dermaßen potenziert das
sind einfach da nichts sagen kann wir
haben ja ich so wenige kinder zumal der
des r15 steigend ist in deutschland und
ich mein ich finde sehr peinlich im
vergleich internationalen dass bei uns
die zahlen steigen also wir werden schon
ausgelacht auf internationalem parkett
das finde ich einfach nicht zeitgemäß
aber trotzdem stellt sich ja die frage
die auch hier in den kommentaren die
ganze zeit kommt wir in deutschland sind
eigentlich eher zu wenig das heißt uns
geburtenrate reicht überhaupt nicht
haben wir ein beitrag auch gerade
gesehen wir haben eher pflege probleme
wir haben eine überalterung der
gesellschaft wie soll das denn gewuppt
werden wenn die menschen jetzt hier
weniger kinder kriegen weil sie tun das
ja im grunde ja automatisch also das
habe ich schon oft erklärt da gibt es
auch von frankfurt zum beispiel das als
professor in schweden
viele artikel und studien und der stadt
auch dass dieser thema demografische
wandel schon positiv gesehen werden muss
und es ändert sich ja sowieso alles also
ich meine das automatisiert sich alles
es gibt schon über pflegeroboter etc
wir müssen einfach auch die senioren das
ist ja so dass die länger gesünder und
fitter sind usw
und es muss sich insgesamt strukturell
halt so wandeln dass wir auf diese
einheimischen kinder nicht in dem maß
angewiesen sind zumal wenn sich das
alles umverteilt und wir dann ja die
vielen einwanderer haben die vielen
millionen klimaflüchtlinge also die
können sich ja dann auch hier einbringen
dann müssen wir nicht wie die union
sagen mauer zaun wir wollen keine
einwanderung wird ist dass wir die dazu
zwingen aus ihren hals
das zu wandeln wenn die menschen die
menschen kommen ja auch hier hinweise
etwa unseren lebensstandard haben
möchten der halt zu einem relativ hohen
co2 ressourcenverbrauch führt dann ist
ja auch keinem geholfen oder na ja das
sollte ja insgesamt untergehen der
ressourcenverbrauch schon schön aber
wenn die dann mal hier sind das die dann
auch anhören verbrauchern das ist schon
klar das bedeutet auf trennen was ist
denn mit den beschlüssen der un
weltbevölkerung konferenz wo sie gesagt
haben wir wollen geld rein geben um
geburtenkontrolle zu ermöglichen um
frauen vor allem auch den zugang zu
bildung zu ermöglichen das ist ja
wissenschaftlich bewiesen wenn menschen
zugang zur verhütung und bildung haben
dann gibt es weniger kinder das ist auch
eine klassische feministische forderung
reicht die ihn nicht das findet
natürlich aber das ist halt jetzt er
bezogen auf zum beispiel wie von sagte
wenn die afrikanische frau statt sechs
kindern nur zwei möchte dann natürlich
musste alles getan werden dass sie das
auch machen kann
aber es geht halt darum nicht man ihre
kinder vergeuden kern ressourcen aber
unsere hier schon und das ist heute da
muss man ansetzen und man darf das nicht
immer total und dann täglich klären
weshalb bei uns leider gemacht wird
förderung auf immer ich habe tatsächlich
noch nicht ganz konkret verstand also
noch nicht verstanden wie sie das heißt
das konkret vorstellen also sie fordern
jetzt quasi die nachkommenden
generationen auf keinen nachwuchs mehr
in die welt zu setzen besonders in den
industrieländern und gleichzeitig ihren
ressourcenverbrauch runterzufahren mit
wer also reicht das argument einfach
tatsächlich dass es ihnen sonst
schlechter geht vor allem auch jetzt mal
egoistisch gedacht ja also viele leute
sparen ja auch ressourcen oder versuchen
nachhaltiger zu leben weil sie denken
ich will meiner erde immer die erde
meinen kindern nicht so überlassen wenn
aber keine kinder da sind ist es ja egal
was ich mache also zumindest aus den
egoistischen kontext heraus gesehen
ja genau das ist eben was ich nicht mag
also das ist wie mir wurde auch schon
vor kurven ich möchte gern hätten damit
ich mal getroffen anschauen kann in 20
jahren
nein ich möchte es unter gerufen willen
retten die sache und der mensch ist
nicht so toll das ist diese widerwärtige
hybris tv in deutschland und wir können
sonst echt nicht leisten historisch in
deutschland ist diese der mensch ist das
tollste von allem da wird
ein haken es gibt berechnungen dass die
beste zahl der in deutschland lebenden
menschen wie 38 millionen also dann
müssen wir noch weiter runter dann wäre
es für die öko kapazität perfekt da gibt
es berechnungen ist so und ich kann auch
nichts dafür wenn leute nicht rechnen
können oder lesen oder sonstwas damit
dann irgendwie schwierigkeiten haben das
ist auch nicht mein problem muss ich
ehrlich sagen aber wenn sie sich zu
hören weil sie sagen die forderung nicht
mehr dass die krassen brauchen das ist
ja keine vorteile ich meine ich zum
beispiel finde ein kind politik gut aber
es kann ja jeder selber entscheiden wer
das möchte das heißt sie fänden es gut
wenn die bundesregierung sagen würde ich
will jeder nur noch ein kind wie wir das
in china ja ziemlich lange hatten was
auch nicht unproblematisch war ja das
kann schon oft der punkt die armen
chinesen müssen weil man hier hatten na
ja es ist schon so zum beispiel die haut
durch diese möchte was wir in ungarn
haben dass das vierte kind da kriegt man
dann so ein suv geschenkt oder sowas und
das ist halt was faschistischen regimes
machen und das möchte ich nicht und
deswegen wäre es ein bisschen besser
wenn man zum beispiel was ich auch schon
oft erwähnt habe dieser club of rome
prämie für kinder frei frauen einführt
damit man mal die progressiven leute die
für die umwelt gut sind prämiert und
nicht nur die reaktionären jetzt
konservativen die dann auch noch so viel
kaputt machen das nicht wollen sie
sicherstellen dass beschließen 80
schieflage wollen sie sicherstellen dass
mit diesen 80.000 euro nicht einfach mal
die große weltreise gebucht wird weil
hey super jetzt kann ich mir leisten
das könnte man ja das kommt mir
irgendwie daran koppeln wo also darf ich
mir jetzt keine konkreten gedanken
gemacht ehrlich gesagt aber ich denke
halt immer was dem sie zwischen
weltreise ist immer noch weniger als die
sind ja leider die meisten das stimmt
schon
naja aber wie gesagt ich kann zum
beispiel ich könnte wenn ich den würde
könnte ich sehr viel fliegen weil ich ja
kein kind hab kein fleisch isst man muss
halt immer schauen dass man seinen
eigenen abdruck in welcher kombination
der einzelaspekten
klein hält das nicht ich habe meine
stimme hier für sie die auch gar nicht
ihrer meinung ist wir haben mal die
publizistin und journalistin birgit
kenne gefragt die sich ihnen so gar
nicht anschließen möchte ich finde es
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich unfair dass wir
das haben den kindern aus baten die
konsequenteste methode für klimaschutz
wäre eigentlich dann dass alle leute die
luft anhalten oder dass wir alle
gemeinsam aussterben aber warum man das
unbedingt jetzt einen kleinen kindern
fest machen wir ist mir erst mal ein
rätsel
ich glaube dass in deutschland
letztendlich wie er das problem haben
dass wir zu wenig kinder haben und dass
es kontinente gibt wo es deutlich mehr
kinder gibt also ich bin nicht sicher ob
das klima sich wirklich beeindruckend
ließe davon dass wir in deutschland
aufhören kinder zu bekommen und wie
gesagt wenn niemand mehr geboren wird
kann auch keiner mehr das klima retten
der ist das quasi die anspielung auf
race for future die ja viel bewegt hat
tatsächlich die kinder die gesagt haben
leute das geht so nicht mehr und auch
unser wetter experte es sind elli mit
dem ich mich heute kurz auf twitter
unterhalten aber weil er ein längeres
video gemacht hat zum thema wann müssen
wir eigentlich etwas tun hat nicht
gefragt ist es nicht eigentlich jetzt
daran dass wir jetzt was machen müssen
und nicht in die zukunft so weit denken
also und er die generationen vor uns
meinen blick nehmen die das alles nicht
so hingekriegt haben
ich wollte schon in folge nicht das war
eine frage an sie das war quasi ein
statement
also ich kann es noch mal ganz normal
ich kann nur nochmals verlieren also
wenn wir das wenn wir jetzt gehen das
ist nicht den anderen die da schon das
getan was ich möchte hören sie mich hört
sich so wunderbar das ist ein bisschen
das die lakers integratoren haben
da ist es schon so also das wie gesagt
was die frau kelly auch gesagt hat das
ist hat dieses beliebte missverständnis
ich habe ja natürlich nichts gegen jetzt
irgendwelche jetzigen dreijährigen
mädchen meine beste freundin hat sowas
auch aber mir tut dieses dreijährige
mädchen zum beispiel unglaublich leid
weil die in wenigen jahren diese ganzen
ressourcen kämpfe kämpfe und sozialen
unruhen und sonst etwas ausbaden muss
und ich an ihrer stelle wird dann mal
sagen ja mutter danke für die tolle welt
die du mir hinterlassen hast und so ein
spruch wie zum beispiel ich nie hören
deswegen bin ich keine mutter weil ich
mach denkt wie kann nicht am kind so
etwas antun wenn alles schon so kaputt
ist also ich finde es dem kind gegenüber
muss ich sagen aber dann wäre das doch
erst recht ermahnt ich habe ja auch
nicht gesagt wir sollen da keine kinder
kriegen sondern einfach weniger
stichwort diese 38 millionen und so aber
dann muss man dann einfach ein bisschen
reduzieren
aber diesen kindern wäre ja geholfen
wenn wir jetzt dafür sorgen dass die
welt klimaneutraler ist und wir dann in
20 jahren zumindest sagen können okay
welt erwärmung auf zwei grad begrenzt
haben wir das noch gebogen hinbekommen
und ihr könnt jetzt doch einigermaßen
noch weiterleben bei uns vielleicht aber
da wird immer das ist auch ein deutsches
typisches problem leider es wird immer
vernachlässigt dass wir in indien jetzt
schon leute haben die umgebracht werden
in wasser kriegen und das finde ich
unglaublich also diesem sommer wurde
eine frau erstochen im kampf ums wasser
und er gut ist es in denen es ist uns
egal weil wir haben ja hier so schön das
finde ich ganz widerwärtig und dagegen
will ich auch was tun ich denke halt ein
interessent die meinetwegen erstochen
werden das will ich nicht also ein
appell von frau braunschweiger für mehr
empathie mit allen menschen auf der welt
und nicht immer nur die egoistische
sicht auf die dinge ich bedanke mich für
das gespräch bei ihnen und sorry das war
jetzt nicht so in die kommentare
weil das waren echt muss ich sagen es
war ein sehr sehr viele wir werden dann
gleich nochmal durcharbeiten
ich bedanke mich auf jeden fall für eure
aufmerksamkeit und sagt das nächste
woche zum nächsten live stream
und wenn euch das stimmen gefallen hat
dann guck doch mal hier rein harald
lesch über das thema gesprochen oder
hier mit luisa neubauer von traders
future und wenn er schon mal da seid
lasst doch noch ein like auf dem abo da